we're told a certain taco stand sells
tea tacos per day for a net profit of
300
each taco costs c dollars to make and is
sold for p dollars
write an equation that relates t c and p
so pause this video and see if you can
do that
all right now let's work this together
so let's just remind ourselves what's
going on here so we have the number of
tacos sold per day is t
so
t equals number
of tacos
sold
per
day
they tell us
net profit of 300
so we could say 300
is equal to net
profit
they tell us that each taco
costs c dollars
to make
so
c is equal to cost
per taco
and then
p is what each taco is sold for
right over there is sold for p dollars
so p is equal to the price
per
taco so how do we figure out what the
net profit is going to be well we could
write it this way
net
profit
is going to be equal to
the total amount of money that you bring
in minus the total amount of money that
you have to spend
so what is going to be the total amount
that you bring in what's going to be the
amount you sell
times
what's going to be the number of tacos
you sell times the price per taco
so t
times p this is how much money you're
bringing in but of course you have to
also subtract out your cost well what's
going to be your cost
what's going to be the number of tacos
times the cost per taco
that's how much we're going to spend so
the number of tacos times the cost
per
taco
now here i've written everything as
variables well i wrote net profit out
but they told us that net profit is
equal to 300. so i could write it like
this 300 is equal to
t times p i'll do those same colors
t
p
minus
t c
minus
t
c
now it's completely possible that they
didn't give us net profit as 300 per day
instead they said that is one of the
variables and they gave one of the other
variables and that would have been okay
we could have used the same logic
whatever they didn't give us we could
have set up as a variable and whatever
they did give us maybe they gave us the
price per taco we could have put that as
a given number
now i know what some of you all are
thinking you didn't get exactly this you
might have thought about it the other
way you might have thought about it as
the profit is going to be equal to the
number of tacos times the profit per
taco and what's going to be the profit
per taco well that's going to be how
much each taco each taco is sold for
minus how much each taco costs and this
also would have been completely credible
and if you look at these two they're
actually algebraically equivalent
if you factor out t here you get this
expression on the right